new surveillance video released of
suspects accused in two burglaries and a
shooting at a chinatown business good
evening to you thank you for joining us
at 8 news now at five i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez vanessa murphy
joining us now live in chinatown not too
far from the scene of that shooting
vanessa police have just released some
new information in the last couple of
hours
that's right and police tell us thanks
to cameras outside here in the shopping
center like this one as you mentioned
the suspect is caught on camera they say
the victim is fighting for his life
there are extra patrols out here and the
department is working to find the
shooter now here's that video a metro
police captain tells us the suspect is
seen in the back of shanghai taste here
he goes inside for about a minute and 45
seconds and is seen running away this
was monday before 3 a.m the managing
partners tell us the employee is chen
yen wong who was cleaning up from the
night before and he was shot 11 times i
think he's lucky
if i got a 11 shot i will die
everybody you know this is just lucky
i hope he
can be
recovered very very soon you know it's
i'm stealing shocking
metro police say they've learned about a
previous burglary here at this shopping
center which was originally not reported
to police police saying they believe the
two crimes are
connected police are asking anyone with
information to come forward they also
say they do not believe this was a hate
crime here at the restaurant the
managing partners tell us they will
reopen tomorrow coming up at six one of
the managing partners takes us inside
the restaurant reporting in chinatown
vanessa murphy live local now